there's about 4 000 calories produced  every single day for every man woman and  child in America and we should only be  eating about 2 000 of them or maybe 2500  calories and you have billions of  dollars being spent by Madison Avenue  and these big food companies encouraging  us to eat these calories  formulating foods that are irresistible  and for most of human history we lived  in this environment of hardship and and  scarcity and now we live in this  environment of over abundance and ease  we are set up for failure in this  country when we go out into the food  environment and 97 out of 100 choices  are bad choices it's not going to change  until we first of all make some of those  choices healthier so that they can be  unconscious and easier and secondly  provide people an opportunity to taste  wonderful Whole Food plant-based and  give them the skills to cook it